design this omixlogic portal and i want
to stress these two words here omics so
a variety of omics types and that
includes phenomics that includes
genomics transcriptomics etc so many
different types of data as well as the
logic part of it and what is really
logic
logic means that we don't just apply in
a textbook fashion
i know how to use this method i'm going
to apply this method to a data set
the logical part of it is always asking
the question why and then asking the
question how and that is what we're
going to focus on in this program why
would we apply a method or how would we
apply a method
so that we come to logical conclusions
because ultimately the goal of analysis
is to extract meaningful insights from
data that are reproducible and that
anyone else can go through the steps
that you have taken and get the same
results right so that's the meaning of
being reproducible and a very critical
factor in this whole domain of data
science and bioinformatics so let's take
a look at how these topics are going to
be organized in the context of this
program so the program consists of
really interactive sessions like today
and we are always looking forward to
getting as much information about you
and about your struggles challenges or
questions before each session so try to
keep that in mind
and then introducing some kind of a
example
project or an example
method
pointing you to resources where you can
learn in detail and in great depth the
specific method or application and then
practicing together so a lot of what
this program is about is not just the
interactive sessions but the actual
materials that you will have access to
because they will fill in the gaps and
provide you with the necessary depth so
that you can
advance in your understanding
so the first part of the program
is going to be focused on
having a good sense of data and
preparing that data for analysis
and then in the second part of the
program we will talk about some of the
methods for unsupervised and supervised
methods of analysis including how to
validate and prepare your methods for
production and so there are a lot of
challenges along the way but hopefully
we will be able to do that if we are
able to combine these as asynchronous
materials that you will be able to
practice through on your own and the
interactive sessions that we will hold
today and so what we will do today is
kind of get started with that process
but i think it's important for us to lay
out the full path so that you have
um
so that you have a sense of where we're
going right where are we going to end up
at the end of this process
so the project
especially will be useful for those of
you that don't want to just learn about
the methods but really see
how these methods are specifically used
to address questions around a different
number of data sets so what kinds of
data sets and projects are we're going
to look at i'm going to give you just a
few examples
in in the next few minutes
so first of all
diagnostics and cancer biology right so
i think a lot of people
have indicated that this is a
an interesting topic
what are some of the factors for
diagnostics in cancer biology so
recently in the past several decades
there has been a lot of progress in
understanding cancer variability among
patients
and specific risk factors as well as
biomarkers that can guide decisions
around clinical diagnosis and treatment
selection so we're going to take a look
at several examples of a project where
that is a factor
the second area that we will look at is
single cell and tissue composition so as
you probably can imagine the single cell
sequencing has really brought in a
tremendous amount of data but also has
required an additional set of methods
that we're going to learn about and that
deals with dimensionality reduction and
again markers for specific indicators or
tissues that we can understand
and then finally we will talk about
other types of data for example
microbiome and infection we'll talk
about infectious diseases we'll talk
about how those are changing the
microbiome or the environment with
microorganisms and how can we analyze
such data and a lot of this data is
going to be available directly from the
public domain so briefly just to talk
about that
as we see in this pandemic there has
been a tremendous growth of the data
that is available in almost real time so
today when you go to ncbi
and you start researching any kind of
topic you will see right away that for
each topic as the years progress there
is more and more information available
and that includes raw data as well as
publications and so we need to
appreciate the fact that the
publications really represent maybe five
percent of the information that is
contained in that data and so there's a
lot of available public data for us to
study and mine using these different
methods but we have to do this with
understanding we really have to
understand the methods and the data and
match the methods that we select with
the data that we would like to analyze
so for that the first part of the
program will also talk about a variety
of data types and so here we have a
connection
multi-omics data analysis and
integration and i will briefly speak
about this
because it's really important to
understand how these different data
types are different from each other so
one type of data for example phenotypic
data phenotypic data could be
characterized in many different ways and
it could refer to raw data for example
imaging can be classified as raw data
or clinical data where clinical data is
really the annotated raw data that is
based on an opinion based on a taxonomy
based on some kind of an understanding
of whatever condition we are looking at
so that all falls under this
domain of phenomics or phenotypic data
the second part that we will talk about
is genomics so what is specific and
unique about genomic data is that as you
know the dna is comprised of just four
different types of nucleotides so when
we look at these four different
nucleotides first of all this is a very
specific type of data these nucleotides
appear together not in a random fashion
but somehow in an interconnected fashion
so the sequence part is very critical
but when we want to compare different
conditions there are multiple ways that
we can interpret the data from genomic
sequencing for example mutability with
frequency of mutations
or
by somatic score how specific is this to
a somatic mutation so
understanding what the data means and
linking it to the right kinds of methods
will be greatly
helpful when you start dealing with
those kinds of data
epigenomics when we speak about
epigenomic signal dna methylation or
whole genome bisulfite sequencing we're
really talking about specific regions
that are present on the dna
and those regions have certain
characteristics they could be methylated
or unmethylated or those could be
several different types of histone
modification so understanding again the
biology of chromatin packing of
silencing through dna methylation and
how we can measure the impact of such
epigenomic data on the actual phenotype
is important here as well and then
finally we will talk about gene and
isoform expression how we can measure
the levels of expression or look at
variation at the alternative splicing
level and decide how do we use this
information
for the specific challenge that we would
like to address
okay great so i see a lot of people have
already done this course
this is excellent that you have done
this course because today is the session
where we will try to load some of these
data types and work with them but
because not everybody has done this
course i do want to have this review
first and so when you get to the
practical session i am sure that you
will
appreciate that much more
than
just doing this without kind of this
reminder so for those of you that have
not done any of these types of data have
not worked with any type of these data i
do want to point you to a course that
you are welcome to take a look at and
that course is called bytes and
molecules so if you go to this tab
called courses
you can type in here bytes
bytes and molecules
and this course will provide you with
the terminology
and examples of how this data is
generated and what does it represent so
make sure that you look at these lessons
and here you have a button called load
more and you can add here some
applications of this data including an
introduction to bioinformatics languages
so if you would if you haven't done any
of this background uh you know training
please take a look at some of these
lessons here
in the bytes and molecules course
okay so what do we do with this data
right so again we have these different
types of data different omics type of
data we have to understand how this data
is generated and ultimately what we have
to do with the raw data sets is we have
to process this data to make it
structured right and so we'll spend just
a little bit of time speaking about what
structured and unstructured data look
like and that will be done in our next
session that will be dedicated to the
different types of omics data
and then we are going to try and analyze
some of this data using our big data
analysis platform and so what's
important here is to really understand
the link between stepwise
processing of data so these are
individual steps they're algorithms we
need to understand the settings of these
algorithms and we need to understand
what do these algorithms actually do
while you understand that it will
provide a much better
understanding of the final output right
and you will be able to answer deep
questions about the results of your
analysis linking it back to where the
data came from and how it was prepared
right and there are a lot of challenges
by the way related to finding data
online that somebody else processed and
not really having a good grasp of how it
was prepared for analysis before you do
the downstream and exciting so to say
visualization and biological
interpretation so we do have to address
that in detail as well and ultimately
once we have the structured data we're
also going to be going to this aspect of
integration because ultimately biology
what is specific about biology is that
it is a complex interaction at multiple
levels that we really have to appreciate
when we take a gene an isoform a peptide
or we take a look at interaction between
different proteins it is the collection
of information around that the context
that really plays a role in our ability
to make a kind of reliable and valid
interpretation of what we are seeing so
what we're going to try and do is very
quickly go through different examples
and placing them back into the context
of what where that biological
system
helps us understand the interaction and
the significance of specific aspects of
what we find during the analysis stage
and so here you can see from sequencing
to comparing different conditions to
trying to interpret protein-protein
interactions or maybe understanding the
taxonomy or the organization of the
different types of organisms that we
have to really evaluate some signal that
we find in a statistical or a machine
learning approach right which is just
dealing with numeric data
so what we will try to do is take that
biological context and then take a look
at this process of reproducible
statistical analysis in order to find
inference right to make some kind of an
understanding that is generalizable
about this biological condition in
general and not only
focus on a specific experiment and what
that experiment kind of tells us right
because we do have to generalize
okay so let me
just pause here one second i see several
questions so let me address those
questions
is it possible that there will be some
exercise related to
immunoinformatics okay so definitely
possible again that is the reason why we
asked you to fill out the survey
whatever you put in the survey if you
are interested in immunoinformatics and
you want to do tcr uh repair tours right
or you want to look at uh you know some
kind of epitope mapping or whatever it
is that you are interested in that is
what we ask you to put in that form
that helps us to learn more about your
background and your interests
indrani is asking is asking definitely
you can find a number of online quizzes
on each of the fundamentals yes a lot of
the fundamentals are covered we have
some coursework on fundamentals you can
also find a lot of
online materials on a lot of these
topics right so the goal of this program
is to connect those together into some
kind of a meaningful sequence of
sessions that hopefully provides you
with a broad view of methodology and a
specific focus on the data science
aspect of all of these together
so
as we spoke about different omics data
let us briefly talk about some of this
challenge with structured and
unstructured data so in reality it is
much easier to work with structured data
but it is not as available
as unstructured data in fact in 2020
over 60 percent of available data was
unstructured and that is why it's
important to understand that most of
these data sets come in an unstructured
way
and once we have access to the
unstructured data we should be aware of
the steps to make it structured and then
we should be able to understand how do
we actually work with that structured
data in the context of a technical
environment that allows us to perform
analysis and get some results and so
we'll talk about today
how to organize our data into different
objects vectors data frames matrices
how to load them how to explore them how
to visualize them etc
we will also look at the significance of
understanding data properties from a
statistical perspective so a lot of the
methods that we will cover in this
program have assumptions about data
these assumptions might be about
distribution about the mean they could
be
kind of you know reliant on different
normalization techniques or
transformation techniques and so we need
to be able to understand what do these
techniques tell us about the data and
how do we find the appropriate methods
for preparing the data for analysis
we will also talk about how this
understanding could be a part of your
exploratory process so that the
thresholds and the settings that you use
in all of these steps have a meaning
right you know how to answer the
question why why did you choose a
threshold of five
or one thousand how did you identify
this kind of a pattern or that kind of
powder what does it actually speak to
both from a biological and a data point
of view
and then we will turn that understanding
into a contrast right so you should be
able to look at
the way your data is organized
and then
make decisions about what to do next and
a critical part of that is exploration
but also it's designing the contrast the
thresholds and the settings that you
should be using and so we hope that we
will address this
in the next couple of
sessions
so after we do that we're actually going
to take a look at a variety of methods
now in data science
i think the most exciting part is that
we have
easy to use methods of data mining
machine learning and deep learning and
when i say easy to use i mean literally
one line of code or maximum several
lines of code to really perform complex
analysis of data and because it is so
easy to use these methods it is also
very important to understand what do
these methods actually do
how do they differ from each other what
are the specific settings that they have
and what are the assumptions that they
have about the data so that the results
are interpretable so that will be a
large portion of this program and we
will cover methods that are unsupervised
where we do clustering or we do
dimensionality reduction and we'll also
talk about supervised methods of
analysis so supervised methods of
analysis like classification and
regression but also we will talk about
how we can use them in a variety of
other ways like using them for
dimensionality reduction to study
features that they extract from the data
or understanding feature significance
then feature selection how do we
actually use those
to understand a lot more about the data
and be able to interpret them
okay so the next thing that we want to
do in today's session and again let me
know if you do have any questions
if you have any questions i can answer
those
but if you don't have any more questions
at this point
i will pass this on to
dr raghav
who will kind of show you technically
and practically how to get started with
some of these exercises now before i
pass it on to him i see a question i am
interested in using nlp
methods for data text mining does that
fit into the methods mentioned here so
we won't directly speak about nlp from
let's say publications or something like
that some of the methods that you will
find here are related but if you're only
interested
interested in nlp specifically and you
have that in mind this program is
probably not going to be the right fit
for you
i do recommend the research fellowship
program where you're more open to the
types of methods so that's something
that we can discuss later so there are
no other questions i will
pass it to dr raghav
and
ask him to
kind of give you some practical
examples of some of these things to get
started with
thank you very much elijah